ma boîte à bonheur texte d'isabelle
loire aux illustrations aurélia moineau
chez océan jeunesse dans ma chance j'ai
une boîte à bonheur quand je louvre je
contemple les trésors que j'ai ramassé
il y a une plume douce et grises c'est
le souvenir de la caresse de maman un
matin d'été le soleil briller et les
cardinaux sifflé dans les arbres il y a
une feuille blanche mon papa il ya
déposé un baiser rien que pour moi je
les plier et je les ranger soigneusement
il y un coquillage rose que j'ai ramassé
sur la plage de sable noir il était
caché au milieu de légumes argenté je
les montre et à ma grande soeur et nous
avons ri ensemble de bonheur il y à un
caillou en forme de coeur je les
trouvais en me promenant dans un sentier
au milieu de la forêt ampli d'arum et
d'hortensias c'était le jour du grand
pique nique avec mes cousins et mes
cousines
il y a une étoile qui s'est glissée une
nuit sous mon oreiller la lune était
ronde je me suis promené avec elle au
milieu de la voie lactée
il y à un doudou tout chaud tout doux
qui me câline quand je me sens toute
seule et perdue dans le vaste monde
il y à une lanterne que m'a offerte une
luciole pour m'éclairer la nuit quand je
fais des cauchemars
il y à un pétale de rose blanche qui
s'est posé sur ma chaussure dans le
jardin parfumé de jasmin et de romarin
il y à un moulin à musique qui me fout
des berceuses pour m'endormir le soir
il y à une perle aux couleurs de l'arc
en ciel que m'a offerte une sirène
ne le dis à personne c'est un secret il
y à la coquille de noix que mal et ses
poussettes avant son mariage avancent
avec son prince charmant et maintenant
raconte moi ce que tu vas rangé dans ta
boîte à bonheur
je vais te faire une confidence quand je
suis triste
j'ouvre ma boîte à trésors alors tous
mes petits bonheurs se met à danser
autour de moi et mes larmes s'envole